y'at-il choisi aujourd'hui on se tombe
sur happy with style bientôt je touche
le sol comme ça on s'en fou aujourd'hui
sur un pee wee ça fait quelques temps
qu'on n'a pas joué et j'en oublie de
jouer mon la soirée partie mais quelle
terrible niveau allons nous donc
sélectionner celui là il a cinq étoiles
ça me plaît c'est parti on joue c'est de
l'allemand peut-être le niveau en fait
tout le temps tu que ce sujet en train
de faire de ma vie on va juste mettre
les gamins de deux ans attendait alors
que le gamin dans les pij arrive pour
t'aider fisto problème de la route
pourquoi ne touchent tous les fesses ça
va pas alors qu'est ce que cette jamais
eu le niveau des chats jail à deux
étoiles sur 5 un tweet dans l'accueil à
lemouchia ne veut pas être noté deux sur
cinq essais il a minimum 6 / 5 drôle
c'est de repenser vite c'est drôle ça te
fait rire - jamie position foetale
quelqu'un se doit de m'expliquer suggéré
comme ça je pense je veux dire avec les
fesses les fesses devant mais regardez
le il s'accroche à la vie kill the baby
foot dans le déni au [ __ ] elle joue
jack aurait défoncé portant mais c'est
quoi ces enfants qui s'accrochaient la
ville arrêter ça suffit je suis frustré
quand je te demande de te prendre un
sable dans la tête tu le prends sans
broncher
voilà d'où il revient mais mal est là la
[ __ ] le calumet l'air il ya un cap
qu'elle a il m'énerve
what you're gonna do you wanna be your
man of works et depuis ça m'amuse
beaucoup elle ferait passer toute la
vidéo sur ce niveau savait qu'on était
tous mes [ __ ] dans ce sens at a fait
une crête mon gala face café non crête
inverse d'une crête à tes cheveux
partout sauf au milieu plus dur que
blood bornes plus dur que dark souls
futur que ma [ __ ] quand je marque c'est
lourd ça c'est lourd obsédé version
regardez ils arrêtent le couteau avec
son pénis comme un javelot un javelot
jeux olympiques à ça fait du bien
vous le savez ça c'est un truc qu'on
roule clause de survie taille c'est ça
non mais dès le communiqué jim est tout
de suite alors dû me s'accroche plus à
la vie j'adore ce niveau voilà calmement
lol superbe ah bah oui le led et qu'il
n'arrive pas à finir il est un cd qui
fini mais 5 le gars qui joue sa vie sur
bwin
un mot donné
et pour ceux qui pour nous tuer aulas
est fatale et non on a perdu mais on
finit comme ça je vous le dis le matin
vous faites ça ça fait vos abdos vos
biceps tout ils montrent une fête une
chaîne de musculation sur youtube un
salut jambes comment vas tu oui ça
marche trop bien ça va chauffer il y
avait un an la vitesse une course
d'obstacles ça y'a aucun problème il
suffit d'aller tout doucement ou alors
de faire sa maison mère ensuite c'est
quoi oui ou non
qu'est-ce que tu avec mes fesses
aujourd'hui jimmy continue est accrochée
à la vie plutôt que de t'accrocher avait
fait ce dieu leur semble j'arrive des
messages sur les phobies pop au mieux on
a gagné
il fait ça aussi après s'être battu san
goku pris le cut au montage et voilà où
ils confort la demie je suis en dirhams
asticots mois là alors faire quoi auquel
il tient quoi ça commence comme ça
généralement tu sais que ça finit pas
bien
vous connaissez la règle le joie que
official plus vite sera mentionné dans
mon prochain niveau vous rendez compte
il part même à los angeles visiter les
studios qui ont développé happy with et
voilà je suis plus rapide le niveau
s'appelle impossible sur une roue
arrière
annonc y avait des mines ça on sait
faire oh pardon du michelin fait exprès
non mais il bloque des matières avec lui
dans la mort un raid est accrochée à la
vie jay mais alors pour qui c'est
impossible
non j'avais mes mains dedans dans la
zone chuck norris joie quand je suis à
messieurs et des larmes ça c'est un gel
pur et aux lectures jumbo
voilà mais j'avais pas nous cherchons la
main alors bon on rigole un vrai quoi on
peut être ces styles et vers quoi pour
être en sécurité position foetale au
plat et voilà un problème
un réflexe fait à la old mini assez des
mini jeux odj est folle
ok c'est parti ok ok ok on y est on est
on y est
amber jamie il a pris un jet ma job
remplace jimmy actuellement mais c'est
pareil ces mêmes effets voilà bah au
revoir born owing jambes aux nombreuses
parades à la mine j'ai oublié à elle m a
publié par contre épreuves suivantes
souple et hop là rien ne peut m'arrêter
peut-être une mine volante la bin ouais
elle m'a retiré siège plus tard gardez
vous verrez sa quête fois dans votre vie
le perso en parfait état sans jimmy 100
sièges merde
balou la victoire c'est la règle elle
tonné des lames when they have
l'espagnol abel ya mon look à cenon
tingaud nl je suis vivant ah oui c'est
pas grave séparables c'est grave jimmy
tu te fait tirer dessus
oui c'est d'imiter près les tu apprends
d'une flèche dont trois deux un djiby bâ
oui bah oui je vais tuer tous les deux
[ __ ] un sou je t'attends tu criais
olaru et dort pas et drôle là bas je
suis partie de la lumière je reviens
victoire superbe lors du mythe
desjardins premier temps tu vas me rende
ma jambe
bon voilà comme ça tu as plein double
moi ça j'y vais à fond de flip et ges au
nom aux six enfants et qui contrôle la
boule jimmy attaque le attaque le
sauvage non atteints par l'épidémie
oui j'ai accroché les deux échappe toit
du temple mais sans aucun problème pour
la yart et d'un [ __ ] faut aller vite
on s'écharpe on sera sauvé notre
attendant le mec quoi la victoire fleuve
mode c'est quoi oui ça me plaît ça on
fait quoi on fait la main délicatement
comme ça à part un redoutable ccg et là
on va se prendre un bain ou
disparaissent à plus vite là on va jouer
james bond pa skyfall mai
ah non non non est le standard de ça et
on s'enfuit on met un plan d'évasion
je vote oui la russie ont fini avec une
scoliose non oh [ __ ] 20 juin j'ai
avancé ses jetons
allez hop ça dégage je vous tous biatch
au monde de faire des pfr de tête tu
fais ton ta pas de chance un taux jamais
on escalade
j'aime et je t'envoie en éclaireur tu
vois quoi dit mais tu vois quoi
qu'est-ce qu'elle autre que j'aime et
c'est ma tête ça [ __ ]
olala qu'est ce que c'est que ça assez
drôle à aa
je vais pas gagner plutôt sage être m 2
je te merde tu peux le compléter ah non
au pouvoir le faire c'est la question
que tout le monde se pose actuellement
attention attention voilà les gens c'est
déjà près de 12 sur un pee wee j'espère
que ça vous a plu et c'est le cas
n'hésitez pas à claquer jimmy et mes
vidéos pardon ne fera pas les enfants en
ces temps très bientôt dans une nouvelle
vidéo c'est en tout cas je sorte un
karim je dis ça je dis rien vraiment
mais ça va regarder tu as du monde pis
[Musique]